Muslims in Norway are now establishing a
Masid and da Center to enhance the
Norwegian daa if you donate to the SC
you will inshallah reap the rewards of
thousands of Muslims coming back to
Islam and many of those will become D
and invite to Islam so click the link
and donate now and share the video for
extra reward
how are you guys doing I'm here joining
with a big Z big Z or z+ what should I
call you I think big Z because then
Ali's going to get upset at it he's A+
okay big Z big Z or you can say the big
dog or the man with the plan or just the
legend
okay zero stick with
that you brought yourself too high so I
had to you know what I mean I had to
give you put me in my place just like
Kevin Samuel I
think just like he putting Nikki in her
place actually to be fair like I made a
video as you know crial of of of Sams
because you know I I just saw it as a
reaction to feminism like this kind of
like red pill movement and stuff like
that and I thought I actually saw a lot
of Muslim people moving in that
direction and I didn't like it because I
realized the problems with it but to be
fair yeah on I think we just both
watched this you know these aspect of
his um video that he done with Nicki
Minaj and I think there's praise that
it's actually due here because he he
handled himself quite well despite that
I do think there are areas of criticism
as well so we'll be looking at some of
that but before that I think let's look
at two main aspects okay let's get
straight into it two main aspects of
this video that I wanted to react to
yeah which uh kind of starts in the
Middle where Nikki herself who is kind
to be honest with you I don't know much
about her but from what I know uh she's
a figure of decadence and if if someone
could personify decadence it would be
this woman um you know uh nothing
intellectual contributed at all she
thinks she's a success we'll come to all
of that starts off by speaking about you
know uh success funny enough and these
other things so I wanted to see what she
has to say coming onto this platform and
then how we can look also at how Kevin
responds so let's first take a look at
what her prerogative is here I'm talking
to black women real quick can we stop
talk can we stop posting all day on T CU
i i i newly went to Tik Tok and I and I
just kept seeing this black women can we
stop talking about if black men if these
successful black men want us or not like
can we just focus on us and we be
successful and then we go out there and
we decide who the [__] we want so what I
see with this Zan bro is like it's
typical Independence narrative success
narrative she's talking about she's
success oh she what is what is success I
mean is Success being famous being rich
I'm sorry to say these are things
assumptions which cannot be justified
and who are you anyway Nikki to speak to
black women as if you represent them you
don't represent them you represent
higher Echelon type individual Western
women you don't you don't actually
suffer from the same plights as the
majority of black people will suffer
from black men or women and you don't
have even a right to call yourself a
success because you are rich and famous
Success is Not defined like that for us
is it Zan no because if you defines
success as richness or fame these are
two things that don't have an ending
like money there's always more money
that you can attain with Fame there's
always more Fame that you can attain
you'll never be able to reach the
Pinnacle absolutely and in our tradition
the Islamic tradition with the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam he
said that if you give a man you know a
value of
gold you know he'll be hungry for
another Valley so in other words there's
always the thing is having material
wealth as you say it doesn't quench your
thirst for these kinds of things you'll
just want more and more and more yeah
and so really there is no POS strong
positive correlation for example with
happiness as a state and uh material
wealth you'll find unfortunately a lot
of the richest people in society yes and
the most famous are those who are most
depressed yes so this idea of equating
success with Fame and money this
capitalistic idea which you have been
colonized into believing is the case is
itself difficult to substantiate from
the very beginning yes so this is the
first thing the independence narrative
here I think is problematic as well
before we go there I want to see how
Kevin Samuels responds to her there's a
lot of hurt on both sides and I recom I
told guys look while you're under 30
work recogn work on getting yourself
together because like it or not you
really not in a position like like you
should be to be able to work with Lee do
anything like that so as you see he
starts off by saying there's a lot of
hurt from both sides now this is not
this is atypical of Kevin Samuels
because usually if a woman Hypes up like
that to him and his uh in his presence
or discussion he will actually shut her
down or even switch her off or something
but I think he's being strategic here
and he's got good emotional intelligence
here to be praiseworthy of him yeah
however his narrative is as good as hers
in the sense that he's also telling men
to just focus on themselves it's an
egoistic gender narrative on both sides
and if it's an egoistic gender narrative
on both sides what you're going to end
up having is an atomized Society with
people only caring about themselves they
don't realize that complimentarity is
needed in order to avoid conflict of
interest in the first place like at the
end of the day if men just think about
themselves and work on themselves not
caring about the opposite gender or
having apathetic attitudes and the
opposite is true imagine what that will
do to the black community my question is
is simple why are the adults making
themselves the center of this project in
these seldomly do I find in these
conversations that children are put uh
first like children are put first we
know through the data that uh nuclear
families and stable families are the
most advantageous for children okay but
for nuclear families to be functional
there has to be compromised on both
sides I would call it like the
individualistic narratives of the West
yeah it is because at the end of the day
like 100 years ago he mentions this to
be fair to him Kevin Samuels mentions
this in some of his discussions he says
your grandma wouldn't be speaking like
that yeah and he's right do you know
what he's right the her grandma whoever
whoever she's speaking to wouldn't be
speaking like that cuz she'd have a more
traditional complementarian nuclear type
understanding of the family but you know
what else is true his granddad wouldn't
be speaking the way he's speaking either
that's the truth as well like his his
granddad will be thinking about let me
how do I provide for the kids how do I
make a family stable how this and that
the problem the problem is not just with
one gender or another it's both genders
realizing individual responsibility and
recognizing individual weakness and then
working together to try and sort that
out and you you mentioned something a
verse in the Quran do you want to
explain yeah so I think this whole
complementarianism is something which is
mentioned by the Quran to the nearest
meaning when it says um you are garments
for them and they are garments for you
referring to a husband and a wife and
did this issue that you're talking about
of individualism is something which is
you know it's it's a disease that's
coming from capitalism and it's
something which is obviously rooted in
liberalism um which which talks about in
individual benefit and of course an
offshoot of that is human rights which
talks about um what we're owed and not
what we owe others there's no human
right that talks about the the rights of
your mother or the rights of your father
and this is a problem and liberalism is
something which is being shoved down our
throat and we're seeing this in in
France this is where we're seeing the
hijab being banned and we're seeing this
now in in Saudi Arabia where you've got
uh you know um liberalism being um
injected into the community and and
other communities so liberalism is an
issue and that's why liberalism does
need to come under the microscope
because it is what is telling us look
the individual and your pleasure and
your pain as long as it doesn't affect
others yeah it's fine it's all do you
know is it's ethical egoism it's not
just psychological ego the difference
being is ethical egoism is like I I um
sorry psychological egoism is about me
it's about me yeah it's about my pain
and pleasure and a lot of us are like
that by by nature but ethical egoism is
where you say it ought to be about my
pleasure first and what we're seeing
really with this kind of conversation is
a proliferation of ethical egoistic
gender discourses yeah so both of them
are just concerned with each other's
okay well black women shouldn't do this
blah blah blah blah blah it's no care
for the kids same thing with him no care
for the kids no care for the other
gender it's a very selfish discourse
either way but let's move on to
something else that he mentions
controversially I guess you know she
asks him how many times should a man
expect to have sex let's take a look at
what she asks and how he responds how
many
times
should a man expect to have uh sex what
is in your opinion how many times should
a woman give their man
sex a week a
week uh I'm I'm a fan of the as often as
he wants
it hold on hold on because here's the
thing it's under here's the thing you
look at like I said I look at guys most
guys I'm talking to are working 10 12
hour days so I actually respect the way
he responds there you know and she
didn't really have much push back after
what he said uh which is surprising to
be honest but I I respect the fact that
he's stuck to his kind of guns on this
one because at the end of the day it's
once again sex is one of those things
okay which is a weakness for men more so
than it is for women it's one of those
things and let me tell you something you
know as many of the viewers know like
Muslim women have to wear hijab which is
more encompassing than what a man has to
cover and so on and so forth yeah and a
lot of people come Muslim and non-muslim
alike and they say like why should a
woman cover up for the weakness of a man
that is the wrong why not the question
is why not why should a man cover up for
the weakness of of a woman if certain
things certain events a fire happened
women and children come out first or a
war happened the men on the front line
these things are clear that there are
some things that men are stronger than
women are and some things that women are
stronger than men are and that's why the
Quran beautifully expresses this in one
sentence the human being is he been
created weak the human being has been
created weak and in fact in this context
it's talking about sexual weakness and
so yeah the idea of a man having
intercourse or the woman helping really
facilitating for the man something which
would otherwise be his weakness
something which would otherwise if it's
not done it can cause greater societal
decadence and Decay because he's going
to go try and find find it
elsewhere pathological Behavior will
start to emerge it will destabilize
families and all kinds of other things
happen he he might start to find her you
know um he might not he might be put off
her to be honest with you it might be a
horrible thing for him so yeah this is
it we're not advocating obviously some
stupid person's going to come out and
say what you talking about rape or
something obviously we're not if a woman
doesn't want to give it you can't take
it from her like that because you can't
cause anyone harm in Islam that's what
we believe anyway but yeah the fact that
a woman wouldn't want to give it to a
man anyways is the mark of a
dysfunctional relationship yeah it is a
mark of but I'm I'm I respect the fact
that he's he's coming out saying this
because you won't find many people
coming out men saying it in the way that
he said that what do you think about
that yeah I think you made a good point
unfortunately and sadly in this day and
age especially in sitcoms when you see
um um a husband and a wife sex is
actually used as a weapon it's actually
used as a weapon kids are used as
weapons and when you start using these
things as Weapons then what you're doing
is you are breaking that that family up
and if if a man can't get it at home if
a woman can't get it at home then I mean
the question now arises where else are
they going to get it from well she does
mention women here should we should we
listen to what she has to say we
continue or let's say what you know a
lot of people throughout my life would
tell me I'm like a man because I
remember I remember people would tell me
I shouldn't want to I shouldn't expect
as a woman to have a climax every time I
do it right Hilton and I said excuse me
are you out of your [__] mind why
wouldn't I want to climax every time I
have intercourse just like you want to
climax when you have intercourse and I
was I was accused of being like a man
not in my you know I'm this is years ago
and I knew that wasn't gonna work CH CA
uhuh it's not only about you okay well I
mean I think you mentioning it before as
well that this is something that in
Islam when you look at the literature
this is something that's emphasized that
it's not just about the man's pleasure
it is about the female's pleasure as
well I mean just like with when we're
talking about complementarianism and
we're talking about both parties then
this actually fits in very well to that
yeah I agree a lot of men and the
Prophet gave explicit advice as like not
to come in and go out straight away even
to to warm up a woman to foreplay all
that kind of stuff very specific this
shows you this comprehensiveness of the
guidance of Islam like women work in a
different sexual manner to men and I'll
tell you something brother like honestly
a lot of men we talk about men
withholding in sexual marriages and
stuff but also women men sorry women
withholding but men move old as well
sometimes like and and that is if you
want to destroy your marriage as a man
then the first thing you'll do is ignore
your woman's sexual needs unnecessarily
yeah you know unnecessarily of course
but either way it's unnecessary like in
the sense that why you no because in the
Quran it does say that you can oh right
yeah of course if she's unnecessarily in
the sense that you know it's not because
she's acting rebelliously or something
like that or of course of course good
point but like what I'm saying is
exactly do you know what I'm trying to
say like if she wants something and
you're ignoring that men need to also
realize that this is a quick way to
break a family and then she what do you
not think that this you're going to
cause her fitna do you not think does a
man not think that by leaving his wife
sexual needs and she wants to do
something and she's prodding him and she
wants to you know engage sexual sexually
with him and he's like kind of like
giving her the cold shoulder or on his
phone or something like that does he not
think that he's now destroying the
family and that he's making a fitna for
himself and for his uh for his family
yeah so it's at the same time like we
have to be fair and just Islam it gives
actually if a man can't sexually satisfy
a woman there's and and it continues and
he's is stopping there's very strong
grounds for a divorce here there
actually I'm not saying that a woman
should do that she should obviously try
and as the Quran says try and reconcile
whatever but theoretically get that
there's ground for divorce it shows how
serious of an issue that it is yeah
there yeah this you can't you cannot
yeah you cannot withhold from either
party and this goes back to the
complementarian point yeah but so yeah
we we agree with that we agree with that
um but generally now before we close off
what do you think of this conversation
back and forth we've already talked
about what's conspicuously kind of
missing here which is mention of the
children and these conversations they
always disregard the children in family
settings what else would you say is
missing or should have been added or
could have been I think what's
interesting here is someone like myself
when I was initially watching it I I
expected K Kevin Samuels to go in full
guns blazing and just smash her to bits
and stuff like that because that's
that's what he's known for and or I was
expecting Nikki to be very Blas and very
kind of loud and you know very I'm going
to represent for the people and all
these women and I'm going to layer on
him I think both of them were clever in
their approach um Kevin respected her um
and she respected him and I think we
were discussing before as well that I
think he maneuvered himself very well uh
in that discussion so in in that sort of
sense on that point actually you make a
good point because at the end of it it's
like this is this actually it might seem
uh like trivial I guess but at the end
he was like I need to go now and I know
that might seem like something trivial I
think it was premeditated personally in
and I think that actually speaks volumes
to the kind of thing as Muslim men cuz
it's not just we're not here to
criticize only Kevin and Nikki well
Nikki we should be criticizing to be
honest she's from the looks of it a
completely decadent character but with
Kevin at least there are some things
which Muslim men can actually learn from
and this is one of them if you look at
the end of this conversation he's like
have you got any more questions because
I need to leave but good to be on here
with you you got any other questions
because I gotta get but the phraseology
is actually very telling here have you
got any questions so he's the he's the
one that's being questioned yeah he's
put himself in the teacher the edifying
position he's the teacher cuz I need to
you know go whatever yeah meaning I've
got things to do I I don't value you as
much as you think you value yourself
he's not saying that in explicit terms
but he's gesturing it through implicit
action because he knows if he does it
explicitly he's risking putting his
reputation at risk with someone of her
social profile you know who is at least
see in the society as successful
although she is not according to us yeah
what do you think of that kind of
maneuvering bro so there's websites
nowadays in which people go and you know
they unlock pictures andan they they
spend extortionate amounts of money just
so they can interact with women and
there's a uh a term which has been
coined called Sing where even in in
games people people pay extortionate
amounts to female Gamers just so they
can kind of sit there and S over them
and stuff like that so this has become a
big problem in our society and for for
us to kind is it there in the Asian
Community as much like it's in every
Community unfortunately as sadly
Pakistani you tell us what's happening
subal it's it's in every community that
that I've seen yeah because the world's
become a global village I think we're
okay you
know you know the highest consumers of
uh porography and stuff like that is
actually in
the it's actually no pornography is
different though we're talking about
this this gring attitude that we call
simping and yeah that's he he
exemplifies a good example even even
when even when you look at the economic
Hitman by John Perkins he actually talks
about you know people that hire up in
certain Arab countries where you're
trying to throw something the you hear
that you hear to
unsubscribe where there's bro they they
pay extortionate amounts just to to to
get white women and stuff like this is
this is a post Colonial sing that that's
what he is so in that sense to to see
somebody like this because Nikki at the
start she actually rated herself as a
seven no she did she doesn't she did
which was interesting but then can I ask
a question yeah sorry I don't you know I
I don't
know yeah I've not heard a single song
from this woman I don't know who this
woman isn't it right I had to research
her after I saw this thing with this guy
yeah okay I'm not just saying that I
know she's famous but she thinks think
she's famous and important I don't think
she is right bro is he he rated her nine
out of 10 right he did yeah I mean is
that something you would say is
accurate I mean is that is that is do
you think he's doing that to kind of
boost her ego or something BR because I
think he is because it was very
interesting because I think you made the
point you said at the start when he
increased her rating the conversation
took a different turn imagine if he gave
like a four uh which I think would be
accurate I checked let me tell you
something sorry to say but I checked the
Wikipedia P this individual yeah and I
saw that she was like 40 like on his
standards I I don't see how his
subjective measuring stick is is is all
over because on his a 40-year-old woman
for him well he he any he says over 35
is gone so how could he be given her
that that number I I think maybe it was
a strategic move because I think with
any of these celebrities so that means
his his rating system is is is flawed
bro or or maybe this was like
exceptionalism maybe it was one off that
he was just trying to protect himself
yeah protect himself and stuff like
because imagine if he upset Nikki and
then he's getting a barrage of thousands
of messages after the ejaculation after
the orgasm yeah after both parties or
one of them orgasms the male orgasms
whatever yeah what is there what is
there what what what is there to do you
I can't no no no what what I mean is
that's done now okay okay you you have a
very very beautiful voluptuous physique
whatever I've relieve myself in you no
problem now what no no seriously now
what are we going to have tea are we
going to eat food are we're going to
talk because at the end of the day
you're not having sex all day they were
talking about sex for onethird of the
conversation you're not having sex all
day if it's going to be a superficial
reality then I'm really sorry it's going
to break families she's going to be
unsatisfied intellectually mentally in
every other way the community are going
to break down as I said it's just egoism
on steroids yeah I think that's a that's
a very good point and a very good
summary and uh I think it it proves and
it shows that Islam has the holistic
kind of view you can go to isms and
schisms and some things that these
people say sound very nice and videos
going viral but at the end of the day
Islam is the dean that comes from our
Lord we have the pixel he has the
picture and if you want a holistic
Unapologetic um objective view on life
then Islam is for you and for me that's
right that's right so you know what to
do niik you convert to Islam you can you
can stop being successful because the
Quran says and I'm going to end with
this which is by
time that certainly human being is in a
state of loss you're failure you're
loser you're unsuccessful all of us
are except for those who
believe and they do good works good
works
yeah and they exalt one another to truth
and they exalt one another to patience
that's true
success Muslims in Norway are now
establishing a mid and da Center to
enhance the Norwegian daa if you donate
to the SCS you will inshallah reap the
rewards of thousands of Muslims coming
back to Islam and many of those will
become D and invite to Islam so click
the link and donate now and share the
video for extra reward